[Music]
it is going to be
one of the jewels of the one belt one
road plan
a mega port in northern myanmar where
chinese oil
and cargo will now be offloaded and sent
to china on pipelines and roads
children
ocean the only ways to ideal for china
but the chinese mega project sits in
rakhine state
home of the rohingya people and site of
the biggest humanitarian crisis
in asia i think generally the local
population
is worried that their government is not
capable
of managing chinese investment for the
benefit of myanmar people
chinese projects have brought investment
electricity jobs
but it has also been met with protests
and controversy
i'm anthony and i've been covering
stories on china silk road for the past
four years but this particular episode
is very personal for me
my parents are originally from myanmar
they met
and eventually had us four kids and even
though we were raised in thailand
i've been coming back to this country
for the past three decades
so i'm very excited to take you along
with me
on this journey to my homeland
my first stop a place that is of utmost
importance on the global silk road
a rural town that will soon undergo
dramatic transformation
so there's black gold down there huh
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh yeah i can definitely smell the oil
[Music]
myanmar is one of the world's oldest oil
producers
exporting its first barrel in 1853
despite its early start production has
been negligible here
[Music]
level
now profound change is about to come to
oil mountain
[Music]
today i'm going to meet utunchi he's
taking me to his home in maday island
where he is the chairman of the
development association
good morning hi good morning good
morning hi i'm anthony
nice to meet you his family has lived
here for three generations
in 2011 thousands of chinese workers
descended on the sparsely populated
island he lives on
and they have come for this
what's that over there yeah
[Music]
this is china national petroleum
corporation's
oil and gas installation that cost 2.45
billion u.s dollars
from here there is a 771 kilometer long
underground oil and gas pipeline
stretching to china
the gas pipeline started operations in
2013
and chinese press reported that it can
carry
12 billion cubic meters of gas to china
annually the sister oil pipeline started
in 2017
and can carry up to 440 000 barrels of
crude oil
per day oil mountain's output of several
barrels a day
is a mere drop compared to the oil
tsunami
that is coming to chauffeur's shores
[Music]
china a vast mainly inland empire
has always looked for outlets to the sea
for its landlocked western
and southwestern provinces
the policy began as far back as the 18th
century
today the xiaopu corridor gives china
access to south and southeast asia
as well as the entire indian ocean
region
this utmost strategically important
c-axis
has now finally been realized for china
here
nearly 80 percent of china's oil imports
which comes from the middle east and
africa
used to have to sail through the straits
of malacca
now these twin crude and gas pipelines
are
key to china's two ocean strategy to
diversify energy supply away from the
choke point
of the straits of malacca when fully
operational
it is expected to supply six percent of
china's annual needs
many believe it will impact
petrochemical businesses
in singapore malaysia and indonesia
[Music]
the completion of the project was
celebrated in china
but here at maday island the project
provoked a different reaction
the myanmar ministry of energy was
responsible for compensating the people
affected by this mega project but utunci
says this has not been done how did the
people in your village
respond to the developments here
at
that seems like unfair treatment for
simply voicing your concern
how
[Music]
into an activist after aung san tsuchi's
party came to power in 2015
utunchi was released now he is
recognized as a local leader
and is involved in regular meetings with
the chinese investors
and also myanmar government
issues like land compensation pollution
and development plans are still under
discussion
though the oil and gas facility is fully
built you hoping that things will be
better once the compensation issue is
resolved
it is not just about the energy supply
chain
there are plans for a mammoth special
economic zone
and deep sea port here the master
developer
is china's state-owned city group
maday island and the islands around it
will be transformed from this
to this city and its partners
will spend an estimated 7 billion u.s
dollars
building 10 berths over the next 20
years
when completed the expected annual
capacity of the deep sea port
will be 7.8 million tons of bulk cargo
and 4.9 million teu containers
annually in comparison the world's
busiest port in shanghai
handled an estimated 40 million teu
in 2017. the child port will be
connected to china
and other major myanmar cities by roads
china's city group says it will create a
hundred thousand jobs
in what is currently a small fishing
town
a plan beyond belief for many locals
i'm traveling on china's silk road in
chao myanmar
and this fishing town is about to be
transformed
radically a huge petrochemical facility
has already been built
and now work will soon commence on a
deep sea port
and a special economic zone
i want to see for myself where the
special economic zone will be located
so i hit the roads
[Music]
well i'm finally here i see
a few huts a lot of agricultural land
and it's hard to believe that a special
economic zone is gonna end up here
[Music]
lives in the area that is demarcated for
the special economic zone
though chinese media reported that work
will begin in 2016.
the project has faced many delays
do you know anything about the special
economic zone that's going to be here
so what are your hopes for this special
economic zone when it finally
[Music]
materializes
[Music]
[Music]
these farmers may not have felt much
impact
but china's silk road has already
brought major changes
to another community here in xiaopiu
xiaopu has a population of 45 000 and
many of them
rely on the sea for a living
the arrival of the oil tankers who need
to pass through fishing ground
has caused concern so how
have all these chinese developments here
how have they affected you
[Music]
know
foreign
but there are also those amongst them
that are eagerly anticipating the future
it may be some time before the special
economic zone and deep sea port takes
shape in this fishing town
first china and myanmar disagree over
the ownership structure
chinese developer cytik had initially
asked for an 85
stake in the xiaopu project the myanmar
government
wanted a bigger stake many in myanmar
cite the japanese-led
kilauea special economic zone as an
example
whereby myanmar owns 51 percent while
japan
owns 49 there are also the geopolitical
considerations xiaopiu is almost
directly opposite
ins varsha where the indian navy will
base its new fleet
of nuclear submarines xiaopiu will be
the fourth and last chinese controlled
port in the area
a myanmar government official told
bloomberg news that military attaches
from the u.s
india and other asean countries have
expressed concern
over militarization of the area in the
past
chinese warships have docked in the
maldives pakistan
and also in sri lanka
finally there's the rohingya crisis
xiaopiu is located in rakhine state the
site of asia's biggest humanitarian
disaster
in recent times
[Music]
aung shin is the editor of myanmar times
one of the most respected newspapers in
the country
and he tells me investment inflows have
come to a near stop
due to the rohingya crisis
how do you think the rohingya crisis
will impact developments in xiaopiu
i just has been to the job field it's
really
huge i mean really potential but so far
now they have done yet for
their special economy state discussing
hong kong and the ruins of crisis
in pattern of course the uh this country
in
the whole country right now you know
every year the whole day economies
are impacted by the ruling check rise
because they invest in
the listening and closing watching all
the time
right what is that really happening
though there hasn't been violence
reported in chao pew the sheer fact that
it is located in rakhine state
complicates matters apart from the
chinese
it has been difficult to rally other
investors
there are many challenges here but it is
unlikely these problems will get in the
way of china's mega plan
the new silk road strategy features six
economic corridors connecting
china to the world and myanmar plays a
significant role
in two out of these six corridors
the first corridor starts from kunming
in southern china
passing through myanmar and bangladesh
through to kolkata in india
it features a combination of road rail
water and air linkages with a total
estimated cost
of 22 billion u.s dollars
the second corridor is the china
indochina peninsula corridor
this features nine cross national
highways linking
all of indochina it also envisions a
railway
that plans to connect china to countries
across southeast asia
down through to singapore
this railway is still at various stages
of negotiation
with the different countries these two
major corridors
join a network of four other corridors
on china's belt and road plan
connecting china to europe china to iran
and turkey
china to mongolia and russia and china
to pakistan
china has incredible political will to
implement its belt and road plan
so whatever the challenges are here in
chao pew it is unlikely to hold the
mighty tide of change
xiaopiu will join a host of other
myanmar cities with strong
chinese influence amongst them
the old capital mandalay
[Music]
[Music]
this looks like a scene you will see in
any city in china
but it is actually mandalay myanmar's
second largest city
and former royal capital
there's the chinese aerobics fashion
apparel stores
huawei phone shops and also a lively
chinese culinary scene
according to official figures there are
400 000 ethnic chinese in mandalay
province
they form almost half of the population
of one million
in this city the chinese imprint goes
beyond the signboards and shops
many of mandalay's shopping centers
condominiums and hotels
are chinese owned mandalay remains a hub
for largely chinese-traded jade
and gemstones as well as smartphones
motorbikes
and other imported goods we had the
opportunity to spend a few days in
mandalay
and there we saw the influence of
chinese
community there from the buildings
hotels
chinese businesses how important has
chinese investment
been for the city of mandalay a member
from uh
isolated for many years so no project at
all
for most of the year the the the consume
they use every day that was there in
portable china
so if you're a businessman in mandolin
you just do it there's some thin
import from the china and easy way and
you sell in the mandalay
in that way they're the chinese
businessman they gotta have from the
china
the other thing is there are many the
chinese people they pawn
into the especially the mandalay area
some years ago
thousand years ago they bought a land
so if you look at the whole city right
more than a half in all the monthly city
belong to the china chinese people right
now
going along with that i've also heard
that if you want to do business in
mandalay
you pretty much need to have a chinese
connection or speak chinese
is that true yes that's true that's true
china and myanmar have deep historical
ties
the roots of it goes back to a violent
period in myanmar's history
since the 1950s myanmar's various ethnic
armed groups
like the kachin the koran the shan and
the wah have been fighting the military
junta
this has been the world's longest
running civil war
the junta ruled over a brutal military
regime for half a century
they locked up aung san tsuji in her own
home for 15 years
imprisoned activists and waged war
against many
ethnic groups what was the relationship
between
the junta and china like between
the 1980s and 90s popular relation papa
means brotherhood
so like uh china is a big brother not
yours
so whatever you need your big brother
will protect you will help you
so the chinese your big brother the only
uh
friends the only the investor that's why
most of the majority of the
state the i mean projects all of them
belong to the china
former british ambassador vikki bowman
has lived in myanmar for 12 years
and eventually married a local artist
the myanmar expert shares her view on
this paul paul
relations over the
90s with the sort of gradual scaling
back of any form of
western investment because of a
combination of the politics and
and sanctions to some extent china
became the only
choice that the myanmar had then as a
partner during that period
and i was here then as ambassador the
chinese
were i think not sort of just standing
by they were also actually trying to
engage
myanmar and show it on the path to
reform
china at the time we're talking here in
the 2000s was taking members of the
military regime
off to shenzhen but also yunnan
kunming to show them pathways to
economic development
so they were certainly
looking at this place as extremely
strategic option
a democratic transition started in
myanmar in 2012.
the world celebrated the fact that
myanmar was finally open for business
but the truth is that chinese companies
have been here
since the 1980s three decades
before aung san tsuji was released from
house arrest
today i'm going to meet joe wynn one of
the most prominent
chinese burmese businessmen in the
country
[Music]
jaw wind is the man behind mingala
mandalay
it's the city's biggest commercial
development and includes shopping malls
villas
condominiums shop houses office towers
and what will be
the city's most upmarket five-star hotel
mingala mandalay and two other major
projects done by chaw winds company
will shape the new downtown of mandalay
it's a massive undertaking
that has already proven successful
there are many successful burmese
chinese businessmen like yourself
what do you think are the factors that
drive the success
of
building the new downtown of myanmar
second biggest city
is a mammoth project but the tycoon's
ambitions extend further up north
along the border of china is the city of
musee
on the myanmar side
myanmar china
two ancient countries are separated by
shwali river
the site is located in the northwest
side mu city
a beautiful untouched land becoming an
important business window
for myanmar and china business
jawwin has planned an entire town here
he has built roads
power lines water facilities and he's in
the process
of building the shops office towers
housing
villas hotels basically everything that
a government town planner would usually
do
except that this is a private enterprise
endeavor
musee currently a sparsely populated
town
is the starting point of china's silk
road in myanmar
i'd like to ask you about the musee
project because that's a
huge show of confidence in the one belt
one road plan
general museum
general one by
believes china's silk road will bring
more investments in these much needed
areas
and contribute to development in myanmar
as the belt and road progresses chinese
businessmen and state-owned enterprises
are building dams hotels
bridges and shopping complexes
they are trading in everything from
fruits to timber
to metals but of all these
none is more monumental than the j trade
jade is huge business
but the jade trade has been linked to
wars environmental destruction
and a drug pandemic
it is 5 a.m but business is already in
full swing
at the mandalay jade market chinese
traders are here
looking for the prized heavenly stone
jade
the j trade between myanmar and china is
worth an estimated
30 billion us dollars a year that is
about
half of myanmar's gdp this business with
china
affects thousands of lives in myanmar
and shapes public perception that
ordinary burmese people have
of china you see all these merchants
shining their torches on the stone
it's how you check for the transparency
and clarity of the best stones
the more transparent it is the more
expensive it is let's take a look at
this one right here
and so they're shining the light and
checking the quality of the stone
and that is why it's so important to
come here to the market before the sun
goes up
five thousand to eight thousand people
come here
every morning to do business some
chinese buyers browse the stalls
hundreds of other chinese buyers sit
around while myanmar sellers present
their stones
this simple looking market here is one
of the most valuable gem trading hubs
in the world
[Music]
burmese jade traders association
what about this piece here how much
would this cost one lakh
oh one lock one lap so about 80 us
dollars 80 years
that's not too bad okay let's see what
else we can find oh
what about this guy it's pretty heavy
how much is this worth
uh two hundred that in my case
twenty thousand us dollars yeah oh man
okay
i better be very careful then putting
that down i don't want to break it
wow so then all the transactions that
are done here
all of them are done in cash right yeah
that's amazing that means there are
thousands thousands of dollars being
circulated all around in the market
yeah yeah well let's check out the rest
of the market yeah
[Applause]
ninety percent of the world's jade
resources come from myanmar
according to a report by london-based
global witness
what's mined in myanmar is worth more
than 30 billion us dollars a year
a transformative amount of money if it
were properly spent
so we're talking about a lot of money in
the j trade
how are the people of myanmar benefiting
from this
[Music]
is
yeah but there is a dark side to the
jade trade
myanmar journalist ninja nazar has been
following this story
for over five years and she has seen
some horrific things
you've been to the jade mine several
times can you tell me what you saw there
in pagan the jake mines there was no
tree
or like it was really dusty after
several decades of chinese business and
the business came in
it became the place where it's really
dry and the environment is really
in bad situation what about the workers
there
there are two types of workers one of
them when is the
company workers who work uh full time
and the other types is the hand because
most of the handbags don't have regular
contact with their family members who
are left in home
so when they die in landslides the
family members they don't even know that
they already die in the last life
landslides take place at the jade mines
every few months
when the government tried to dig out the
bodies from the side which collapsed
because of the machine it is really
hard to know who is who because
the machines rip apart the bodies and
also
like the bodies are already decomposed
that sounds absolutely horrific
[Music]
drug addiction among poor miners is also
a major problem
miners take heroin to ease muscle pain
and many get addicted
the problems in the jade mines are well
known in myanmar
there are many problems associated with
the j-trade
land grabs slave labor drug addiction
do you think that the chinese should
take
more responsibility for these issues of
course they just
because they are the the only issue we
find out right
they cheat mostly done by the the
chinese company
all these ones none of them never have
any knowledge
about the responsible business or csr or
whatever
for many decades they didn't care they
don't know it because nobody tell us
so the chinese government over the last
10 years or so has come out
with a number of guidelines around
environmentally and socially responsible
investment
sort of going out guidelines and so on
my observation from here is that they
seem to be somewhat stuck in beijing
um they are not even filtering down to
some of the chinese soes who are here
let alone small private sector chinese
companies who are involved in the jade
trade
for a business that is worth 30 billion
us dollars a year
the j trade has the potential to bring
transformational benefits to myanmar
but in its current form it is a
blood-stained business
as the silk road progresses there are
more calls for socially responsible
investment
the myanmar government is now looking at
more regulations around the j-trade
and many locals hope the chinese
government will also step in
to punish errant chinese companies
china is keenly aware that the
perception of the new silk road
goes beyond mere infrastructure projects
and special economic zones
and that's why there's been a charm
offensive happening in myanmar
[Music]
today i'm headed to the china myanmar
friendship association
and here to show me around is the vice
chairman
there are several china myanmar
friendship associations in the country
and this one in mandalay is the largest
a museum was opened here in 2017 to
educate the public
on china myanmar ties
so it's a burmese legend that goes back
several hundred years yes
it's beautiful
um
so this is an example of the
relationship at a government to
government level
so i guess what you guys are doing is
more at the grassroots level
i've seen impressive infrastructure
projects along china's silk road
but what really stands out for me is
seeing how much effort china has put
into promoting goodwill
all over the world
soft power complements hard
infrastructure on the new silk road
and here is a spectacular example of
china's
infrastructure spending in myanmar
[Music]
i am traveling on china's new silk road
and i'm in myanmar
it is a key site for large-scale chinese
projects
including the dams ports roads and
bridges that are the concrete and steel
manifestation
of the one belt one road plan
[Music]
completed in 2007 the yada naban bridge
connects north and south myanmar
the company responsible was camc
engineering
a chinese state-owned company
before it was built big trucks needed to
cross
using a river barge the old bridge
built by the british wasn't strong
enough to support the weight of these
vehicles
just looking at the landscape here it
tells the story
over there you see the pass built by the
british
during its colonial glory days in the
1930s
it is now a dated piece of
infrastructure
and over here the future the modern
technological marvel
provided by china and its silk road
this is a massive bridge and i'm sure
there were challenges while building it
can you share a little bit about that
so if you had to import all the steel
from china that must have been difficult
given the
road conditions at the time
of
what are your thoughts on the new silk
road and what has been your experience
living in myanmar for the past eight
years
so this is one of the villages that's
close by to the bridge yeah yeah yeah
it's very near to the bridge and
also mean street uh where we'll
introduce
the benefit yeah because you being here
during the construction i'm sure you got
to know a lot of the locals around here
yeah yeah yeah previously
sometimes we go to have the dinner or
that
yeah so right now i will introduce
nice to meet you old home was demolished
to make way for the construction of the
bridge
what are your thoughts on the bridge
as land prices soared after the
completion of the bridge
um cashed in and sold his land
the money was invested in a textile
factory which he now runs
out of his new home he is full of praise
for china's silk road
and how it has improved his life
the yanda naban bridge was one mega
chinese project
here is another yewa dam
it is one of the largest dams in the
country and it provides electricity
for the city of mandalay dams are
controversial in myanmar
but not this one here at yewa
environmentalist maumau explains how
yewa
not only generates electricity but also
prevents flooding
and natural disasters
foreign
is just one of dozens of major dam
projects
that china is involved in in asean
in myanmar china has planned eight major
dams
in cambodia it is building three
in laos it is building seven in vietnam
one and in malaysia two
these do not include the dozens of other
minor dams they're building
of all these dams one of the largest is
the mitzon dam located in kachin state
chinese officials said that it will
bring renewable energy to myanmar
but it has faced strong opposition
[Music]
the ferocity of reaction against the dam
surprised even the chinese
in 2010 a series of bombs struck the
dam's construction site
killing and injuring chinese workers
fresh rounds of fights also broke out
between rebel kachin separatists
and the myanmar army over the dam
if we can look at the mitzon dam in
particular
what are the issues surrounding it if we
think about where
mitzon is being proposed it's where the
ao1 actually forms
ayawati which is the most important
river in myanmar and
is providing livelihoods to millions of
people
putting the dam right there will
obviously have a lot of impacts for
people living downstream
but also for the ecological functioning
of the river
for fish migration for ensuring that
there's sufficient water downstream
during the dry season
a people's daily report in early 2014
said china had invested at least 700
million yuan in the project
by the time it was halted china's
ambassador to myanmar
visited the dam site in 2016 and
proposed
several solutions to the deadlocked
project
one cancel the dam and pay 800 million
dollars in compensation
resume work and earn 500 million dollars
a year
when it is completed or do nothing and
pay
50 million dollars in interest every
year
the decision is a daunting task for
myanmar's leader ong san tsuji
who risks angering china if she cancels
the project
or the public if she lets it go forward
as of 2018
the mitzon dam still remains in limbo
the mitzon dam may have been halted
but more than a dozen other chinese dams
in indochina
threaten the mighty mekong river and its
tributaries
[Music]
it has already become a political issue
in indochina
60 million people depend on the mekong
for their food and livelihood
their ways of lives have evolved over
generations
in tandem with the annual monsoon rains
and the rise and fall
of the water i just hope it won't be all
swept away
in the great flood of progress
[Music]
of course there are no real easy answers
here
i'm a big fan of green energy but if
it's at the expense of 60 million lives
then we've really got to stop and think
about that
dams new towns roads bridges
mines and museums china's belt and road
is one big belt
and an enormous road one that will
encircle
and possibly entwine myanmar
the chinese government has firm ideas
about how myanmar
fits into its bold global master plan
and its two economic corridors
the question is how myanmar will respond
what are your thoughts on china's silk
road
clearly having a massive neighbor like
china on your door with
a desire by them to um invest
is fundamental and existential for me
and my it's the most important
relationship that myanmar has and always
will be
it's a bit like mexico's relationship
with the us nobody's going to step in
and change that one thing very clear
is myanmar need more investment you have
new capital investment so you need
someone who has
capital investment you have a new
technical new home
so you need someone who has it right so
that's the two but it's not the easy
case because this can be really
complicated
and complex situation you have to speed
at the same time but you need to be
careful at the same time
it's not easy at all chinese business
already have bad image in yama such as
the
postponed hydropower projects in gachan
state missile
and also in pakin the jade mines because
of the
previous incidents myanmar people think
that they don't
work transparently i think the
government has to
work on that terms with the chinese
government and the companies for one per
world project
for them to be more transparent and
sustainable and responsible business
in the country
i love this country it's where my family
comes from
and where my history lies i love its
rivers and quaint towns
and warm people and rich culture
progress is coming and it's a good thing
but there are fears it will sweep away
so many of the things that ordinary
myanmar people treasure
the balancing act of maintaining
investment flows from china
and protecting local interests is not
going to be easy
there is public fear of losing control
over myanmar's economic future
but we have to work towards a win-win
situation and accept china's silk road
but in our own way on our own terms
and in our own time
[Music]
you